I'm delighted to have as my guest today Theodore Sorenson who is known to the world
as the trusted advisor and close friend of the late President Kennedy.
Mr Sorenson is author of a bestselling book about President Kennedy and is currently practicing
law in New York. He is also an editor at large of the Saturday
Review and recently wrote an article for that magazine called The War in
Vietnam how we can end it. This is our incident you broke a four year
silence about Vietnam with this article which was critical of our course in the war and
called for an indefinite hold in the bombing of North
Vietnam and an increased effort to get
negotiations. Why did you decide to speak out
now I felt that the time had come for the supporters of
the administration to run
against continuing on our present course of escalation. I had not spoken our
previous lane because I am well aware after my years in the White
House of the burden the president already bears without my adding to them.
Of the information which he possesses that I do
not and of the need to give the president
some opportunity and discretion in foreign policy. Without dividing
the party in the country here at home but the present course has
had a fair chance to work and it's not
working and I think those of us who are concerned ought to speak out
now in a recent television interview Senator Robert Kennedy suggested that the
original aims of our involvement in Vietnam have been shifted by the Johnson administration in your
opinion is this true.
We get into some very fine semantic problems they're not so certain that
it's quite
us black and white as both Senator Kennedy and those who
interpreted him have put it the fact is that
President Kennedy put his.
Helping the side off the enemies obtain their own
self-determination helping them secure their own country against
terrorism and the emphasis now is much more than it was
then while admitting some overlap on the
United States taking a stand against world communism
in Vietnam. So that we do not have to take
it in how a or on our west coast
of bombing villages in Vietnam so that we will not
have cities bombed in America that raises as
Senator Kennedy suggested very profound moral questions and
that is
symbolized by the fact that American forces have virtually taken over the
war which President Kennedy had hoped would not ever have to
happen in the winter of one nine hundred sixty five when it became evident that
Southie Timmy's government could not withstand a communist takeover. If you had been an advisor
to the president would you have advised an American troop
commitment a real question is What are the options which faced
this country at that time were we limited to a
choice of a communist military conquest on the one
hand and United States forces taking over the war on the
other the whole.
Thrust of President Kennedy's policy was to prevent us from ever being faced with that choice.
Perhaps we were faced with the bin the winter of one nine hundred sixty five which case it
was a difficult choice between two very undesirable alternatives and President
Johnson's selection of one of those is understandable but I don't know that we
were faced with that hard choice that there were no other alternatives but
there was
no political or diplomatic action. Could have been
taken no insistence upon reforms on the part of the south of the enemies. Before
we made a commitment to a point where they can now resist our suggestions for reform.
So you suggesting that it might even involve able to become more
involved in internal domestic policies south you know put more
pressure on the kind of reforms that might make the government popular.
Yes we cannot run their government for them. We cannot impose democracy upon
another people. It's a little foolish to say that we are fighting for their
self-determination if we are denying them self-determination. But
a guerilla war can never be successfully
countered by a government that is unpopular.
That is despised and feared that
is unwilling to distribute
land to clean up corruption and to have.
Reasonable and fair policies of taxation
and government administration and
social services. That's the problem that confronts us in Vietnam today the
South Vietnamese
government is by no means accepted by the
people it is still largely confined to
the Mandarin the elite who control most of the land and most of
the wealth does not have support in the villages
outside of the major
cities and it is in those villages that the war is going to be won or lost.
So the United States is pouring
in its men then materiel and money.
In a cause that cannot succeed until the south of the
enemies do something about their own government and.
Some years ago before we made that kind. That investment of our men
and materiel was the time to have insisted upon those
conditions of course when we were beginning to increase our involvement.
President Kennedy sent more it buys from six or seven hundred
to fifteen thousand advisors. It was at a time when probably the
worst dictator of all Yemen
was. Leading the country and was considerably less popular than even the government
of today.
Lie have a hard time. Patricia and comparing
dictators who is worse than another is hard
to say actually Z.M. when he first started up had a good deal
of
support and was entitled to it on the basis of what he was able to do
for the economy and for the education of the enemies and
for setting up a reasonably stable form of government.
The trouble is that the longer he stayed in power the more he or pressed
his political opponents the more he became dependent upon
his brother and his sister in law Madam new the
more removed he apparently became
from reality and out of touch with his own
people and.
President Kennedy you. Unfortunately was not aware of.
These trends in actions and standing until
the it was too late and as you suggest we had increased
our commitment I don't pretend that
the Kennedy administration is free from blame
for where we are now in Vietnam. Mistakes were made them as
well to do as you suggest in your in your article that a
bombing sensation may lead to negotiations or at
least be a
necessary prerequisite before there is even any chance of that. I wonder what your reaction is
to a recent statement by Dean Acheson where he said there is no possibility of negotiating our
way out of Vietnam. The only way to end the war is to convince the communists their efforts have failed.
Do you think negotiations are feasible unless the communist feel that they really have no chance
of getting their own way and
so
peace is going to come into the anomaly when both sides decide it is preferable to war.
Of course our efforts to prevent a communist military
conquest are aimed in that direction.
I would think that we may have succeeded in doing that they should know by now that they are not going to take over
the South militarily.
They see now a somewhat more legitimate government
and somewhat more viable economy in the south. The time may
well come then when they would prefer a negotiated
solution to continuing the
fighting the trouble is we don't know Dean Acheson doesn't know
I don't know the only way to find out is to stop the bombing and see if they will
negotiate because they've made it very clear as a matter of principle.
Whether you and I think it's a good principle or not is irrelevant. They have made it clear as a matter of principle
that they will not negotiate while we are bombing their home and.
Many experts seem to feel that and noisey is going to hold out until after our domestic.
Elections and that nothing really and no matter what kind of
peace offers we make they will not be accepted what do you make of that assessment.
I think that's very likely I don't think that we want to put ourselves in a position where the north of
the enemies are determining
our
political actions and as I mentioned if they
decide that peace
is better for. Them than war. Negotiations are better for them than
fighting and we will have peace and they will open negotiations.
No matter who is president and no matter whether it is before or after the
elections but there is reason to believe
that they are hopeful. Perhaps deceiving
themselves that the elections will bring about such a change in
the American government that they will be able
to obtain a better bargain for negotiating
table and there is some feeling also that
they are suspicious of President Johnson and unwilling to trust him
at the negotiating
table. But as I say that that
is not a matter that should influence Americans in the presidential campaign we must choose
our presidents on the basis of who is going to be the best man
for our point of view not from the communist point of view.
Do you think it is possible for President Johnson to change his course now that
he's committed so much of his prestige and so much of American resources and
lives to winning the war in Vietnam.
You
would not have to be a dramatic change President Johnson has said himself on more than one
occasion that a negotiated solution is the only sensible solution in Vietnam.
He has said as Dean Rusk has only
recently that we are looking and listening for ways to engage
the other side in the goshi ations. I think if we look and listen the little
harder and stop the bombing which the president has also done before we
might I emphasize the word might find the negotiations
could be
started now you mention in your article that we have never put forth
a mutually acceptable plan for negotiations that
we've had a great deal of rhetoric but very little can. In Crete. He's a
big step to build plans.
Do you doubt the will and resolve of the administration to negotiate.
I don't want to get into personal criticism of the
administration.
I think that the administration rather naturally is looking
for an English eating position that will not be vulnerable to
political attack and
congressional criticism there is no such thing go shooting position. There is no
solution no settlement in Vietnam that is not going to be
risky dangerous with many
disadvantages with many
deficiencies and subject to the bitterest kinds of attacks from the hawks and the
militants and the military and the Republicans and the Southern Democrats and others
on Capitol Hill and the president and the rest of his administration might as
well realize that right
now I would do what you feel the reaction at home would be if
we withdrew from the unknown and did not win the objection. The objectives of
the state.
Depends what you mean by withdraw them depends what you mean by objectives I think that the
American people are not in favor of surrender and they're not in favor of a
humiliating withdrawal which we go back on our commitments
to those Southie enemies
and we asked to stand up for their own independence. On the
other hand I do not think that they would be that kind
of negative reaction to a negotiated settlement.
Which assured the existence of a Sufi
in which you prevented a military
conquest of South Vietnam. Which protected those of
the enemies who did stand up her own government from a slaughter by
the North Vietnamese that in my opinion would be securing our essential
objectives. I think the consequences internationally would
be if it proved that we could not win this kind of
guerrilla war if we were brought to the negotiating table and a coalition government
came about and it became clear that we
couldn't actually defeat the kind of war that we were trying to put
down and I think it's already clear that we cannot actually defeat that kind of war no one has
ever defeated that kind of war guerrilla wars don't end in that
fashion and because there is a change in the in
the atmosphere
the water becomes too cold for the fish
to swim
in under
the order saying a mouse a tongue so
that the world already has a pretty good
idea of the limitations of American bombers
and American heavy arms in trying to
prevent. Grillers from coming down a jungle trail not very
effective Mr Thornton What is your
reaction to the point of view that this threat of
international communism has become much less great in the last few years with.
The rift between China and Russia and that it's no longer
the obligation of the United States to
to intervene and get involved in guerrilla wars and wars
of national liberation.
The term international communist movement has considerably less meaning than it
had before and consequently I think less of a threat to the Soviets are
no
longer threatening in the same
open military fashion that we once feared the
Chinese are talking that way but they have been much
more cautious in
their actual attempts
to cross borders with.
Troops so that we cannot ignore
the conflict of interest between ourselves and the
Soviets and Chinese and their various
allies we cannot ignore the differences in human
values ideologies.
We cannot ignore the attempt they will make to expand their
sphere of influence at our expense and ultimately
to our political
diplomatic and economic
disadvantage United States does not want to be alone in the world that would be
bad United States and would be bad for the world so that any system
which threatens
to erode the survival of other
democracies and friends the world around is one which
we cannot simply smile and say it's none of our business.
But I
I do not think that we face the same kind of united aggressive
threat that we faced ten or more years ago.
Returning to the home scene. What do you think is the effect of the
protesters on policy do they make any difference might they
have an effect in changing our policy in Vietnam.
I think that the obvious.
Presence frequency sometimes prevalence of the scent
on Vietnam cannot fail to have an effect on
the Congress which in turn has its effect on the president presidents
are properly given a wide latitude in the exercise of foreign
policy but no president has ever been able to ignore public opinion
Tarlac. The war in Vietnam in the long run is going to
be ended. Not because of
our superior. Military
power but because of our superior brain power because we come up with some ideas because we come up with
some alternatives because we come up with some solutions and therefore I think it is a good
thing for our university campuses and others to
be offering constructive criticism
and suggestions. But if
by protesters You mean those
who try to block action
in the Pentagon stop the selective service centers from
operating those who
make
a practice of violence in the name of
nonviolence those who act in the
strangest illegal ways calling for a moment of
silence for Che Guevara.
Or burning themselves in before the United Nations or.
What have you that does not influence our foreign policy in the slightest.
It only persuades the president that he is right because he is opposed by a lot of kooks.
You know only discourages the Congress
from participating in this kind of criticism because they
do not want to be associated with that kind of extremism and the
average American who watches these demonstrators on his television set at home.
Besides that he had better abandon those dovish thoughts that he had and it's hard
because. Dogs are not reasonable
and creative constructive people other hand.
Coaching
men who view the news in somewhat the start of
perspective reads that fifty thousand Americans are surrounded
the Pentagon and he thinks our society is on the verge of collapse and it would be food. Was for him
to engage in negotiation.
So they are simply hurting their own cause when they resort to
extreme tactics I'm convinced that the extremists are not
the dominant
figures in the protest movement but because they say they are the
most
wild and exaggerated. Statements
and present a rather colorful picture with their beards and
their feed the press and television naturally give most of
their attention to these extremists and it gives the whole peace movement a bad name.
Eugene McCarthy is running for the Democratic nomination nine hundred sixty eight.
As a candidate that wants negotiations and as
you say to the bombing. Since this
represents something close to your own opinion. Do you support soon because I
think now we know.
I think that until. President Johnson announces whether he is a candidate.
Until center McCarthy demonstrates whether or not he is a serious candidate that
any kind of statement of commitment would be premature.
I admire Senator McCarthy stand on Vietnam.
I admire
his intellectual capacity and his legislative record
on a great many issues but he is not a serious candidate in
my opinion and I'm a realist in politics.
I think that if the president desires to be renominated he will be renominated.
I think he will be opposing. A Republican such as Nixon
or Reagan who will take a much less desirable position
on Vietnam.
That it will be important to defeat that Republican candidate and I don't intend to do.
Say anything now which will make it more difficult for us to defeat that
Republican candidate next fall.
Do you foresee a time in the in the near future if there is an escalation of the war and there's increased.
Dissension in this country where Robert Kennedy will feel obligated to try to get the
nomination in one thousand nine hundred eighty eight.
It's not a matter of whether he feels obligated or not Robert Kennedy is also a
political realist and he is well aware of the fact that even if he entered
and won every single presidential primary there would not be the slightest possibility of his
being nominated president over Lyndon Johnson who is the incumbent.
Do you foresee a time when Senator Kennedy will be president in seventy
two Well Patricia one nine hundred seventy two
is five years away.
And so much can happen in five years in
politics that it's not really worth speculating
about five years ago I was in the White
House life was very different. So the sound of Kennedy knows
that he doesn't know whether they'll be a Republican president then he doesn't know
whether Johnson will been reelected and whether Johnson will been reelected
and perhaps died so that there will be another Democrat incumbent president who's eligible for reelection
and no one has the slightest idea
when Senator Kennedy will have a clear shot at the nomination so for him to
be making any plans on it would be
foolish to indulge in in speculation for a moment
longer there have been many people that
are predicting an increase in violence in this country. Daniel Moynihan
even said that he first saw it at the time of an outbreak of terrorism. What is your
assessment of the of the state of the nation and the way things are evolving in this country.
I don't believe that we are on. Verge of guerrilla
warfare but I am very concerned
about the STATE OF THE NATION. I think that a
malaise as such all over the American people
traceable in large respect
to their inability to see the war in Vietnam
and
the conflict in the cities in the proper perspective.
Some people are violent. Some people are simply irritated.
Some people are taking out their frustrations on
government and on foreigners and on taxes and on trade.
Some people are protesting and marching others are simply indifferent
to the print world problems. I don't
like to see that President Kennedy had a marvelous
neck for putting these problems in perspective. He didn't
expect everyone to agree with him he had many enemies but at least
the country was thinking it was alive or was debating constructive
courses that we should
follow and I regret
the the fall from that high
standard given as recalcitrant Congress and
a reelection of of the consumers of coalition. Do you
feel that more programs could get through Congress is it likely that the kind
of measures that are necessary to forestall the increase in riots
and dissent among the negroes. Could it get through the Congress as it's
constituted I doubt it certainly not without a lot more.
Leadership a lot more education a lot larger effort
to stir the American people to realize how they must meet their
responsibilities. To face up to the problems in our cities
the treatment of minorities and the need for
legislation and large expenditures
to alleviate those problems and alleviate the now.
Many critics in the New Left feel that it's just impossible given the system that we
have and the power structure that we have that the country will respond in time.
What is your feeling about this.
My feeling is the same as Winston Churchill's statement of some time ago that it
is the worst system except for every other that's ever been
tried and I would not willingly
ended for any kind of dictatorship from the new left or from anyone else.
Mr Sorensen thank you for this interview. My guest has been Theodore
Sorenson formerly special counsel to Presidents Kennedy and Johnson and
currently a lawyer in private practice and an editor at large of the Saturday Review.
Thank you and good bye for now.